alors la répartition des postes à
l'assemblée n'est pas terminé on désigne
aujourd'hui le la le président ou la
présidente de la commission des finances
est ce que vous allez vous entendre avec
les républicains pour barrer la route à
eric coquerel delà de la nuit mais c'est
ce que vous allez bâtir un front tout
sauf sauf coquerel à écouter je crois
que l'heure n'est pas aux
tripatouillages les français nous
envoyer un signal très clair ils veulent
une assemblée nationale qui correspond
au panel des opinions des français c'est
une chance c'est une chance démocratique
alors on va pas commencer à faire des
petites ententes d'arrière boutique en
revanche est une tradition dans notre
république à l'assemblée nationale c'est
que le président de la commission des
finances soit issu de l'opposition la
première force de l'opposition
aujourd'hui c'est le rassemblement
national et nous présentons la
candidature de jean philippe tanguy
quelqu'un qui a par son parcours
personnel professionnel par sigle
rigueur à sa rigueur personnelle serait
tout à fait dans le hall et en face on à
monsieur coquerel monsieur coquerel sait
qui c'est l'ultra gauche radicale c'est
la haine des entreprises c'est le
matraquage fiscal c'est la volonté est
de faire une acquisition sur tout ce que
possède tout un chacun même s'il est
bien sûr très honnête donc moi mais cela
du fait majoritaire donc si mélanie que
ça ne veut rien dire je suis désolé
parce que
l'alliance avec les républiques quand ça
les arrange la nuque c'est un groupe
consolidé quand ça les arrange il se
divise en quatre groupes pour obtenir
plus de choses il ya un moment il va
falloir arrêter avec cette mascarade
eric coquerel représente un danger pour
la république non pas en tant que
personne et en tant que les idées qu'il
porte le comportement de la nuit baisse
à l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui on
le voit bien de blocage de cris de coups
de buzz ne sont pas ne correspondent pas
mais si l'on peut considérer que c'est
un danger puisque vous nous dites pour
vous c'est un danger car et coquerel
soit la tête de la commission est ce que
vous allez lui barrer la route on nous
lançons un appel solennel
solennel à tous les commissaires aux
finances à l'assemblée nationale de
voter pour notre candidat qui est le
candidat de l'opposition qui représente
le sérieux le travail et la possibilité
de travailler en consensus et non pas un
agitateur extrémistes comme monsieur
coquerel est ce que vous cherchez est ce
que vous voyez voter pour la candidate
des républicains enfin c'est une drôle
d'idée pour l'instant les républicains
ne sont pas la première force
d'opposition ils sont même parfois
d'ailleurs pas toujours dans
l'opposition donc là tout ça est un
scénario vous appelle
évidemment dans le respect de nos
institutions de nos traditions ça fait
quand même tout ça effectivement
tripatouillage et évoluer politique à
l'ancien nom non justement en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que toutes ces règles
qui se sont impliqués pendant tout un
tas de mandature on redécouvre
aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait peut-être
rabat finalement comme si le
rassemblement national on va peut-être
faire une exception pas d'exception nous
sommes un parti républicain nous sommes
le premier parti d'opposition de france
et nos électeurs valent autant que les
électeurs des autres partis nos députés
valent autant que les députés des autres
partis et donc les mêmes règles doivent
s'appliquer nous avons eu deux vice
présidences c'est tout à fait normal
c'est là aussi traditionnel alors scellé
[Musique]